Live stream is starting soon.
It's starting soon.
It's about to start. It's about to go
down. Livestream is about to go down.
In fact, it's probably already going
down. Oh there I am. Oh, we're all,
it's Raj.
Good to see you guys.
And all squad is in the building.
Let me shout out some names.
Igor. It's patchy. Mick,
Raj Sudan shoe, Brennan. Yo,
we got the whole machine wearing
squad in the house right now.
Who is ready to learn some tensorflow.
I'm so excited for him.
Some tensor flow as to Gora Spencer.
All right.
All right. All right. All right.
Okay, cool. Hi everybody. Hi. Hi.
Okay, so let's get down to
business as they say, Mama,
let's get down to business
and defeat the loss function.
Okay.
So anyway,
let's start off with
a five minute Q and a.
So,
so hit me up with your
most intense machine or any
questions or you just want to
know, you know, anything.
I'm just, we'll go for it.
And then we're going to use tensor
flow to classify housing prices. Okay.
It's going to be dope. It's going
to be the first time. Reason,
tensor flow from scratch in a live
session. It's gonna be awesome. Okay,
so here we go. Hi. Hi.
Hi. Hi. Hi. Let's begin.
I'm doing good. I'm doing good. I'm so
down. I do have a sore throat, but like,
you know, I'm a human. I know,
but like, it's crazy, but
it's, it's cool. It's cool.
Um, what kind of method approach do
you use to manage your time, Mick?
Great question. I, so, um,
what do I use to manage my time?
I write down what I'm going to do for
the whole week before the week starts.
So every Sunday I'll write down, you
know, the, the weekly goals I still have,
I have a weekly to do, to do, I have
a daily to do, I have a monthly to do,
I have a yearly to do and
then I have a five year to do.
So I plan things out in intervals
like that. And, and I made it,
I made sure my goals are accomplishable
goals so that I get that positive
feedback so I can keep going.
It's Google released its own o s uh,
chrome, chrome, ios. Yes or language. No.
Are only python recommended books on
computer science or cryptography. Um,
your cryptography is so dope. I wish I
could just deep dive into cryptography.
That is like some ancient Egyptian
pharaoh mummy. You know what I'm saying?
Like you,
you have to a good book on photography
is my book decentralized applications,
the best selling software engineering
book on Amazon for 2016. Um,
and a good book for machine learning
is machine learning a probabilistic
approach by uh, I forgot the
name, but that's the name of it.
What do you think of Star Wars? I
Love Star Wars. I'm actually not like,
I love the old ones.
The new ones,
like I was kind of
disappointed by episode seven.
So it's like whatever cause kind of
conservative that offer. Disney's parks,
we have to make our own stories.
Guys. We are a new generation.
We're gonna make our own stories
and they're going to be as good,
if not better than star wars.
And we're gonna have a machine learning.
It's gonna be dope.
And when we make stories,
it's going to be technically are accurate.
What if there are more than one local
minima and gradient descent Algo?
Great question. So that's so um, yeah,
so sometimes we have more
than so graded descent.
It's like it's like a three d
graph with the valley, right?
We want to remember what I
talked about last lecture.
You want to drop a ball and
football and see where it fits.
But what if we have multiple values?
Well then that's when I was a second
order optimization function comes in.
We have defined the local minimum that
is closest to that is that it's uh,
going to best optimize our function.
We're going to talk about that later,
but the keyword to remember to say
second order optimization function tensor
calculus,
that's exactly what we're going to do.
So you are not at a low level but at a
high level because uh, tensorflow is,
I'm going to do a little
bit of magic for us.
Can you explain nats behind tensorflow?
I will absolutely find the map to flow is
better than torch. Exactly. Hey, sprout,
are more layers always better in a neural
network? A great question. Tomorrow? No,
not always. Not always. Usually it is.
But uh, so if you have a smaller Dataset,
you don't really need that many layers.
So remember with, with machine learning,
there's always a trade off.
There's always a trade off.
And in engineering in general, there's,
and in life there's a trade off as well.
But, uh, we, we want to, when
we, when we optimize for,
uh,
so when we increase the layers,
we increased the computational complexity,
but we also increased the accuracy.
So there's a trade off.
How should I prepare for Google brain
residency program interview Kaggle,
Kaggle challenges are great. And
the tensorflow intro docs, uh,
watch all my videos,
but you probably already have a,
if you do all that and you apply the code,
you'll be good to go essentially. Yeah.
That's the book name.
Can you give new research idea that
can implement intention flow? Yeah.
So here's an idea I've had for a while.
Somebody should go with this,
take the synthetic radiant paper
from the mind synthetic grading.
So they kind of like stopped
using backpropagation just
for this paper and then
take the idea of one shot when,
so, so probabilistic programming.
And then combine these two ideas together.
So synthetic gradients and
one shot learning, boom,
there's your landmark paper for the year.
I don't have time to do it.
So someone just rolled with that.
It's central, usable in Raspberry Pi.
Yeah. Actually somebody
made a wrapper for Arduino.
So two more questions and
then we're gonna get started.
How does genetic algorithm bit into
machine on the genetic algorithms are good
for optimizing hyper parameters for us.
And when we talked
about that for a second,
so I've got some emails from people
who are like Ah, on the hosel articles,
what people like,
what do you think about this?
We're a Google are using machine learning.
Google is using machine learning
to optimize and she's running.
So like what do we do guys?
Machine learning is not going to take
your jobs away. Okay. We will be.
Um, so if even if there's
a, even if there's a job,
apocalypse machine learning engineers
will be the last people to have jobs.
Not that that's going to happen.
We're going to create new jobs and the
new data at climate and we're going to
have basic income and things like that.
Hopefully through cryptocurrency. Sec,
check out my posts, social point. And it's
already possible. And also branch point.
But um, don't worry about
machine learning, replacing a,
your job as the mission
you want to engineer it to.
If that actually happens that we solve
intelligence and then there's no,
the idea of jobs and money and scarcity
all goes away anyway. Okay, so let's,
let's,
let's go ahead and start yet.
Let's go ahead and get started
if everybody started wanting it.
So to start my course, which at
this course. Okay, so what, okay,
so that's the prominent
today or we're gonna do,
we're gonna use tensorflow to
classified housing prices. Okay. So, um,
that's what we're going to do and I'm
going to use a Jupiter notebook for one.
So let me go ahead and start screen
sharing immediately and we'll get right on
into this itch.
There we go.
Okay.
So
let me move this chat window over
here so I can still see you guys.
I don't need to see myself,
but I just need to see you guys.
And then I'm also have a
timer so I can see myself.
All right.
New movie recording.
All right. And then that
goes away and I'm right here.
Okay.
Minimize myself.
Yeah, the one time it's kind of blurred.
Uh, I'm going to get a better one. Okay.
So here's what we're going to do guys.
Okay.
So we have a housing datasets.
Uh,
one shot learning was the name
was the other thing. Okay. Okay.
Someone do that. And just in general,
one shot learning. So we need more one,
her name, uh, Congress because no, not
everybody has a huge datasets and fusion.
Fusion power. Okay. So I'm going
to explain things slowly this time.
Okay. I'm going to, thanks
Alexandra. Much low. Okay,
so I'm going to explain
things slowly this time. Okay.
So I'm going to start off by talking
about a neural network. Okay?
So a lot. Okay. We see this image
a lot. I'm a neural network, right?
But the one thing I want to say is,
it's the only circles we call him neurons.
They're not actually objects,
they're not classes.
These are just representations of numbers.
Let me zoom in a little bit. They
just represent numbers, okay?
Because when we input data into a
neural network, into a neural network,
in tensorflow,
we clot a computation graph.
Um,
and these are not,
these are not actually like neuro objects.
When we take, when we take an input,
let's say like, you know, well we're
going to do housing prices and we apply a,
when we apply, uh, some matrix math to it,
it's going to take that value and it's
going to do so if it's a one value and we,
we multiplied by a
matrix of safety values,
it's what you did to become
a three or four values.
Those values are what we represent as
neurons. They're not actually objects.
And we take those values and a place that
had matrix operations to them and then
boom, it's a next set of neurons. But
he's neurons are not actually classes.
They are values. Okay? So that, I just
want to start off with that. So that's,
that's, that's that. Now, let
me show you guys the graph.
We show you that to date of first. So
here's the Dataset. I mean, let me,
let me zoom in on anonymous. Okay,
so this is a set up housing prices.
Okay. So the first one did the
index, would you have been a number?
Then next one is the area
which is the size of the house.
The next one is the back, the number of
bathrooms, then the price and then this.
And then the price per square.
The price per square inch.
Okay? So that's what that is.
What we want to do is we
want to classify this,
but this isn't a class but we
don't have labels right now.
We're going to add labels,
okay?
We're going to add labels
where it's going to be a good,
where it's going to be either a good bite
or a bad box. Cause what we want to do,
and these with given one
of these features, okay,
well we're going to decide
what feature for use.
But given one of these features we went
to then classify the house as either a
good or a bad bottle. Okay. So let me,
let me shut down my screen for a second
just so the bit rate goes up a little
bit. Okay. I want to, I want it
to be not that lobby. Okay. So,
so that's what we're going to
do. Okay. So that's our data.
So let's go ahead and start doing
this in a Jupiter notebook. Okay.
So I'm going to do it in a
Jupiter notebook. All right.
So the first thing I want to
do is talk a little bit about,
let me just make sure that this works
first. No, let's see. Yeah. Okay.
Works Great. Okay, so tensorflow, why are
we using tensorflow in the first place?
So, uh, yeah, so this trip is going to
be, let me, let me make the font bigger.
Actually,
the fun is,
let me see.
Okay.
Where are you central flow?
Because Google created it for, oh,
this is going to be a
supervised problem. Okay. Yeah,
it's price per square foot.
This is a supervised problem we're using
tensorflow because we have intention
flow. We are, uh, tentraflow was created
by Google and it was built to scale.
If you use it for many
years, they released it. It
was kind of like, you know,
use coming down from Olympus and
getting fired to the humans. Right.
We know that tensorflow can scale.
We know that it's reliable because
it's used in production. By Google,
I mean Google search uses tensorflow.
Okay. So this is a reliable library,
although high torch is pretty cool too.
It just came out this month
and it introduces the concept
of dynamic computation
graphs. Usually we have
two interpreters, right?
We have a python interpreter
and then we have a, um,
a computation and interpreter.
But what ty torch does is it has one
interpreter for everything. Okay. So, um,
and so Jupiter notebook is really as a,
it's a great concept. Basically
you can, it uses an a,
it allows us to view our coat and had
marked down for code and lets us add,
um, a bunch of pretty
things to our code. Yes.
Prometheus's the rights, uh, answer
that I was looking for. Okay.
So let's go ahead and start by
importing Marmot tenancies. Okay.
So we went to classify a problem and also
let me show you guys what are your own
bed? Looks like. I didn't show you
guys what is it going to look like? So,
so this is what it's going to look like.
Okay.
So we're going to feed in to inputs and
we're going to apply a set of weights
and biases. Use the softmax
function and then output, uh,
the housing price as well as the,
the label,
which is good or bad. Okay. So, um,
we'll talk about that in a second.
Let's go ahead and first import import.
Our dependencies are all right. So
yes, I'm focused on the content. Thank
you. Pull up. So here we go. Import.
Candace has PD. Why Candice? This
is our beautiful library to, uh,
work with data as tables worth with
at our first Lego. Okay, so
next one is none Pi, none Pi.
It's going to help us, uh, use numbers,
use number of agencies.
Both Penn is intentional needed,
so use a number of agencies.
Okay.
The next thing is mapped up
light because we're gonna,
we're gonna show this graph. We're going
to show this graph and in second, and
uh, what else? We want maps out,
lives quite clots as PLT.
I prefer tensorflow,
hi, plot to terrorize.
And finally you tend to flow as FTA.
Okay, that's it. Those are
our four libraries. Then we
can go ahead and compile it.
Boom. So because there are no
errors, we can keep going. Right?
So that's a great thing about Jupiter
slash I python notebooks is that they like
you compile as you go so you can
see, uh, you know, what is happening.
Okay? So that's what we did there.
Now we're going to load the data,
not so that was, that was so step
one is to load data, load data.
Okay? So let's go ahead and locate
it. How are we going to load data?
But we are going to
use the pandas, uh, uh,
library to help us do that.
So the first thing we're gonna do is
we're reaching use. The campaigners reads,
gets the function because
we have a CSV file. Okay.
Um, so if we're going to read
this in as a data frame object,
so what does a data frame
object data frame object.
It's an object in memory that Candice
creates from a CSV file that we can then
easily parse. And I'm going to show
you what I mean by easily park.
So we're going to take this data frame
variable that we just created and we're
going to, uh, list what the,
we're going to remove the
columns we don't care about.
So how do we know which columns
we don't care about? Right?
So let's go back for a data for a second.
We have several columns here,
which are the ones that we want to use
to predict if a house is good or bad.
Well, what we're going to
do is we're gonna take out
the index because that's not
going to really give us anything. It's
just a numbering of what each column gets.
The next one is, uh, the, uh,
let's say area and bathrooms, right? So
those are the two features that like,
we're going to use area and bathroom for
not gonna get the price for the square.
We're not gonna use this
price, this, the square price.
Because when I looked for a house, I
want to make sure that, uh, it has,
I have a certain, and that's
just what I'm using, right?
Deciding which features to
use is its own. It's, it's,
it's its own discipline in and of itself.
What teachers should be used.
And a good rule of thumb to go by it is,
is um,
what features would you personally
use to make a prediction? Okay.
Um, yeah, let me, let me, um,
give you guys this data. How
do I, um, got to stay to, oh,
I can create it are just so kind of just,
I'll say,
let's just take off this,
let me give you guys this data real
quick and I'll paste it into the chat.
So you guys haven't said so data
that Tsp and we'll create a public.
Just boom and I'll paste it in the chat.
Ready?
Get ready for this guys and the
patient. Then boom, there's your data.
That's the data file. All right, so
now you guys can do that along with it.
All right. So we are going to remove
the features we don't care about.
Okay? We're going to remove the
features we don't care about.
We don't care about the Christ. We're
not going to care about the square price.
Speak only won't care about the,
the back, the number of bathrooms.
And what was the second thing?
The area that's,
that's what we're going to
be using right now. Okay? So,
and access is one because
for we're only gonna use the first
axis from the Dataset. All right? So,
so data frame about drop. So
that's who we removed too. Let me,
let me say what we just said here.
We've removed the, we removed Xe,
uh,
features we don't care about.
All right? So we removed the
teachers. We don't care about,
now we're going to only use the first
10 rows in the Dataset and this example.
So we only want to use the first 10
of these, right? Right up to here.
Right up to here. Okay. No Oxford, I
don't want to define that. Okay, so,
so how do we say that?
Well, easily enough.
The great thing about a Beta
for an object, if we can
say, we can say I wouldn't
from row zero to write 10.
Ooh.
So that's going to tell us
that we want to only use,
we only use the first 10 rows.
That's it.
Okay. So that's it. So now we
have our data frame object.
So let's go ahead and print this.
And here's the great thing
about python notebooks.
If we can now print this and see what we
have and you'll give us an error if it
doesn't work. Okay. So there
we go. You've got it in text.
So let's see what I did here. So on
this line, data frame dot drop, uh,
it's pointing to
his access equals one.
And the problem here is invalid syntax.
Uh,
so we have index square prize,
uh Oh yes.
So it did. Okay. So the, this
bracket actually goes here.
That's where the profit goes. Now let's,
let's compile. Okay, so there we go.
There is our beautiful clean for medic
data and we're only using the first 10
columns and we're just using, uh, the, uh,
area and bathrooms as our features.
And remember,
feature selection is an entire
discipline in and of itself.
And we could have used the square price
and we could have used the price as
features, but what I'm looking for
or the area in Bachelors, okay.
That's what I look for when
I try to predict if a house
is a good buy or not for
me. Okay. Um, so, so that's,
so now we have our features. So
let's introduce our, our labels.
So what we just did,
so step one was to load the data and
set two is going to be to introduce the
labels because right now there are no
labels. So we could just do a regression,
right? Because we can then
prevent the next value.
And what do we use regression for for
predicting the next value in a continuous
set. Uh, so that's what we do for
that, but we'll, we're going to do,
if you were to convert this
into a classification problem,
so add labels cause that's our step two.
So we're going to take
that data frame object,
and if everybody doesn't have the data,
go ahead and ask and then someone's
going to paste it into the chat.
The link to that, uh, just, all right.
So what we're gonna do is
we're to introduced the
labels. So we want to say, uh,
our labels are going to eat
a good buy or a bad product.
And so how do we represent
that? Well, for simplicity sake,
let's just use binary numbers,
right?
So a good buy is a one and a bad by the
zero. So that's just randomly had like,
you know, a set of purpose
for our 10, for our 10 values.
So we have to count 10, right? So we want
one, one, one zero, and then, you know,
add some variety in there. So let's see
how many that is. That's three, six,
nine. But we want, uh, we have one,
one zero zero one and then zero and okay,
so again,
it's $10. So we're going
to add on labels. Um,
and so that's,
so what is good and zero is back.
The one is good and zero is bad.
Luck.
Okay, so one is the advisor
was that way. Now, um,
now you can see the first part of the
code. Let me, let me read paste the link.
I'm going to replace the link from,
okay. You can pick some. Okay.
So now you can't see the first part
of the code. Well that's, let me go
that I just, I can't go back.
We have to keep going. Okay,
so one is the goodbye is
there is a bad bottle.
So we can define our set of labels.
Now the next step is to, uh,
turn true false values
into ones and Zeros.
So we're going to say the
location variable is going
to define those labels for
us. All right? So,
so let's go ahead and add the,
uh, the white t values, which,
which will,
so why too.
Um,
and we're going to use a data
frame object, whereas wine one.
Okay,
so what did we just do?
So what we just did is we said why
two is a negation of why one, right?
So we defined why too,
as a negotiation.
And a [inaudible] is a dictation of
why. One. It's the opposite. Opposite.
Okay. Um, right.
So today's the actors. One is,
is the, is the column, okay?
So now white. So why to me we don't
like a house. Why do you need,
we don't like a house. Okay. So let's
go ahead and define why two. Okay.
Different unlock location.
And we're saying, okay,
so what is that value that we want?
Um, why two and then we'll say, okay,
so we're going to convert it
to my needs. Value, right?
We always want to remember that for
tide we're converting to is an in.
So how do we convert it to an evaluator?
Uh, so we're going to take as type.
And so what this says is
if it turn true false
values into ones and Zeros,
so turn true false
values to ones and Zeros. Um, okay.
And now we've done that. And so now
let's print out what we have here.
Let's see what this looks like.
Great thing about high python notebooks.
We can just print what we have here.
We definitely have a syntax error.
So there it is.
And I think soccer mentioned this earlier.
So we are going to add two line three.
So which one is that?
Our uh, brackets? Yes.
Just like that. Okay. And
so now you have an extra.
Okay. Okay. So what did
we do? So we added labels,
but instead of saying good or bad,
we had to label.
So this is just for simplicity sake,
we don't want to convert text to integers
are just going to say it in a raw
value. So, so why?
So why one has a value that means that
is a good buck and every time why one has
a value every time.
Why one is one y two will be
zero and every time y two is one,
why one would be zero. Okay?
So that's just our way of,
of labeling our data for now.
Okay.
So we've added our labels that was set to
remember step one was to load the data,
which we did into a data frame object.
We parsed it.
And then step two was to add
the label to that data. Right.
Which makes this a classification problem
is group. Would you classify this data?
Okay? Where would you
classify housing? Uh,
if a house is a good buy
are bad by based on the,
on the area and the number of of
backwards. Okay. Not Bedrooms. Right?
Um, well I guess, I mean the data didn't
have bedrooms did it? Okay. So, but yeah,
bedrooms would probably
be better if we have that.
So now we have all our data
in a data point. We have to
shape it in major system,
feed into intention clusters.
Now step three is to
prepare data for tensorflow.
So depending on which machine
learning, uh, library we're using,
uh, we can, we will prepare it
a certain way. But in general,
in general, no matter what data we have,
we're going to convert it into cancers.
So 10, let me explain what tensions
are. So, um, so tensors are,
it's a high level of,
so cancers and so tenters are generic
virgin of made of vectors and matrices.
So, um, of vector is so like
vector is a list of numbers.
Then vector is who different up.
This is important because
we see these words.
I love to take your list of numbers.
Then a a matrix is a
list of lists of numbers.
Okay. So then, so a vector
would behave, one d tensor
matrix would be a tutee torture.
And then whatever a risk of
lists of lists of numbers is,
would be a three d 10 Sir. And
then that just continues. Okay.
So attention is like a very generic term
or both matrices, matrices and vectors.
And these tensors are half or how we
represent data in tensorflow, right?
The guy's machine learning neural
networks. It's all just matrix map.
It's a collection of operations
that we apply to some input matrix.
And we continually apply him like a chain
of these operations until we get to an
output. And then we, and then we
apply an optimization function to, uh,
to minimize a loss. And I'm going to talk
about that in a, we're going to do that,
but that's what this is. Okay.
So, so that was a little short,
like a thing on Pinterest for a second.
But to get back to what we're doing,
so we're going to take our data frame
and
we're going to say, uh, let's see.
We want to take the area and the bathroom.
So we're going to take our features,
right?
We're going to take our features and
we're going to convert them into tensors.
We're going to convert
our Peters and detention.
So convert features to
10 to include tensor.
That's, that's what we're going to it
in burn features in anything tensor. Um,
and this session will be 15 minutes
or probably an hour. We'll see, uh,
as matrix and the we went to,
we went to say, okay, so as
a matrix, that's an advert.
So now we're going to convert
our labels, uh, to, uh,
but to answer as well, right?
So let me show you guys this,
this image again. Okay. All right. So,
right, so here are our, just like right
here, this, these two purple circles,
those are impotence for as
our features and our label.
So we're going to feed that into a second.
We haven't created our weights yet.
We've just,
so if you just look at everything,
but these two purple lines that,
sorry,
these two purple circles and that's
what we just created. Okay. Um,
so now, uh, so that's
what we did for that.
So now we're going to convert our
labels in future surfing. Okay.
So I'm sorry, our labels, if you
tend to have a data frame dot low,
sometimes they're already probably
going to happen. So we'll say, okay,
so location and then we'll,
when were those labels that we created
and you guys are gonna be easily have,
um, one label. It's, well,
I'm just, you know, is,
um, okay, so I got to
focus on this. Let's see,
let's see. It just compiles.
Okay, so syntax error, what
do we have here? So, right,
so the extra back brackets.
All right, took area bathrooms.
Um, we have location. Okay,
so Disney supplementing
and extra bracket here.
And then what else do I have here?
So for why one,
I have a bracket or when you get another
bracket and then we'll compile that.
Let's see what else we got here.
Oh, comma aren't Jupiter notebooks.
So great guys, we can just continue. We
can just, we can just compile as we go.
We can just compile it as we go. A
different dot. Location. Y One y two.
What's the dealio? Okay,
we're going to remove that.
We want to say what is going on here.
We've got y one y two die
location and this is a practice.
Oh,
let's see. Oh, okay. Let's see what's
going on here. Whoa, that's a lot.
None area bathrooms are in the
columns. Hold on. A second.
Bathroom in the cops. Uh,
let's see what we did here.
So he sat data frame dot location.
We converted a area,
bathrooms to as a matrix.
Um, and then we said,
okay,
hasn't matrix.
Interesting. Okay, so right. But
so we did have very about terms.
Um, remove the closing brackets. Um,
remove the closing brackets on
or move this one and we
want to add interesting
missing quotes. Oh, there it is. Right?
Missing quotes. That's what it was.
Oh my God. Okay. Yes. Alright,
there we go. Okay, good.
Sturdy for a second. Let's,
let's print out what we had here.
So what did we just create? Ooh,
so what is this? This is what our
[inaudible] matrix looks like. Okay.
So we have the area in the backyard and
this is what our labels matrix looks
like it's pronounce aren't labeled Matrix.
Okay? So that's our implementers
and events are lady Matrix guys.
We have our inputs now we're
going to prepare our printers.
And so what step are we on?
Now we're on step four.
So step three was to prepare the data
for tensor flow so we can format in our
data for tensorflow flow.
And now why don't you step four
is to write out our hyper Kuranda.
Okay.
So what are our hyper parameters?
So the first one is going to be our
learning, right? And so when did we last?
You've when you, right, we
use the learning rate, uh,
when we last life section.
Do you sum that up? We,
the learning rate controls
the rate at which we learn,
you know, so with a better recommendation,
we're learning rate. You're find, um, uh,
how fast we reached convergence to be
technical convergence is when our model is
that it's optimal fit.
When we have that optimal hit where the
error is minimized and the learning rate
defined how fast we get
convergence, we, we had to say,
you can just say,
oh mate,
the loading rate a million and just get
there as fast as possible because if you
go too high then your, your model is not
going to converge. If you go too low,
it's gonna be too slow. So remember,
like all things, it is a trade off.
That is a word of the day,
particularly is a series of trade offs.
And go as straight off to talk,
maxing get the training.
We're going to train you think 2000 times.
And why don't you thousand? I
don't know. I mean we could,
we could try 10,000 in a second.
I don't know what I'm saying. So,
and that's what we, we, we train for
a number of the box with your results.
And then we say, well, is this,
is this prediction accurate
or not? And then if not,
then we'll change. Or two of are
hyper parameters. And again, okay,
so then the number of displaced sex.
Um,
so how often do we want to display?
Uh,
so then how often do we want to display,
uh,
the process of training
and the number of samples,
which is going to be the size of the
number of labor, which is 10. Okay,
so that was our hydropower.
Those who are hyper parameters and now
guys we weren't ready to compile and make
sure that we're on is to
create our computation brand.
So a bit uncomfy vision,
create our computation graph
slash neural network. Okay,
so convocation grab neural
network that the same thing.
But before we get to that, let we do one
quick review of what we've done so far.
We imported our dependencies.
Then we loaded our data,
which is a CSV files a dick.
The data can take a bunch of features,
but we only wanted to use the area
and the bathrooms as our features.
We removed everything else
using those two things.
We went to predict if a housing
price is good or not. But guess what?
There are no labels in our data.
So what did we do?
We added labels because data frame
objects are really easy to Parse,
add data from, remove data from. And
so we added labels. Why? One is when,
why one has a value one, it means it's a
good vibe. When y two has a good value,
that is uh, that is,
uh, it's not a good bottle. Then we
prepared our data for tensor flow.
How do we do that?
We looked at our data for an object and
we converted our features into an input
tenser and then we convert our
labels between a potential as well.
We printed them out, we defined our hyper
parameters. And now we're going to do,
we're going to write out
our computation graph. Okay?
So,
okay,
let's go ahead and write out
in our computation graph.
So let's go ahead and do that. So the
person, I'm going to do these crazy,
I'm going to create a placeholder for
our feature inkling tensor that we just
defined.
He'd put bets.
And what this is doing is so
okay
or [inaudible] for our feature
input teacher input pencil.
So in flow we'll feed it will
feed an array of examples.
Each example will be an array of to
float values area, a number of bathrooms.
And so none means any number of examples,
you know, could the fund,
which is usually the backsides,
but we can say we're just going
to say none. So it's just generic.
We can say however many we want,
I will allocated. That will help.
We allocated a number of beforehand.
And this allows us to have a number of
examples and are two because that's the,
the size of disinfectants are.
Okay.
So I'm sorry, not 32 to
that. My, my mistake.
So two, because we have two features.
Okay. Um, and, and it's a cutie matrix,
right? Because we have two
features. So we've done that.
And so the next step is
to now create our weights.
So create another thing that
placeholder up vet are gateways.
So play folders in flow.
Our gateway for data.
It's how we feed data in for a computation
graph or may wait for data into our
computation graph. All right, so
the next step is you create wins.
So how are we going to create our weights?
So we're going to define our weights.
Has W and we're going to say F. Dot. Gary.
Carryable and so we can upload widget.
So we'll define our weights and it's going
to start off as a set of zero because
we haven't, and that's how you
should start off your words. Um,
for a simple example like this, um,
although with transfer learning, uh,
you know, your weight aren't zero. They're
there, they've been trained beforehand.
So this is a two by two float matrix,
two by two float flotations and,
and we're going to keep updating them.
We'll keep updating
through the training process I
thought we were going to do. Uh,
and so why don't we use a variable well,
intenser flow of variable is,
uh,
when they variables hold
an update parameter.
So variables in TF,
cold and upbeat parameters,
and you'd have weights.
We have weights or any,
any other things you want to,
so they're,
they're basically in their feed memory
buffers, campaigning. Tensors okay.
Um, to be a little more
technical about it, but
these are our ways. Okay. So the next
step is to add our biases. So, um,
we're going to add our
biases. So advisees. And so
we want to biopsies, right?
Because we have too many points.
Um,
but we want to buy two because we
have two inputs and we're going to,
this is also going to be
ATF variable. Um, okay, so
just say two by two matrix.
There are in fact that out.
And we're going to close the bracket
here and add a closing parentheses.
Okay? So let's see what this
actually what we're going to do. One.
So let me show you that.
But we have so far,
so now what we've done is
with printer input tensor,
we have any actually uses little square
thing and we've created our weights and
now we're going to add our biases.
So this is what we're about to do.
So we're going to have these other
purple square looking, uh, dots.
So yes, we're gonna use that combination
to update or within a second.
But first we have to define our biases.
And why don't you use biases?
Biases are going to help, uh, our model
fits better. So a good example is like,
so an example is the in the y
equals mx plus B equation like that.
So because we take that line,
it adds the y intercept would make,
which makes it fit better. So that's
what biases do date. They are there,
there are a part of the larger, uh, uh,
goal. They, it's like, you
know, if you didn't have,
be in the labels and I suppose be the
line wouldn't be to the red line that
you're looking for,
right? So, um, okay. Um,
and I'll, I'll go over everything
we've done at the end guys.
So right now we've added our biases
and so the next step is to, uh,
calculate.
We're going to perform some matrix back.
So now we're going to multiply
our rates by Howard inputs.
So this is our first calculation
that's happening here, right?
Because weights are what we wait for,
how we govern, how data flows in,
in our copy,
wait for how we govern,
how data flows in our communications.
Okay.
So let's go ahead and perform this.
So we'll say we'll define it
as y values and we'll say,
and um, we'll say yes. Wait,
can we can initialize weights as
random as well? Um, and depending on,
you know, what you're
doing, it can be different.
But right now we're
initializing kind of zeroes.
And to perform this actual
matrix multiplication step,
the has this great built in Matrix
multiplication function, um,
uh, that we can say, okay,
so take mark he puts and then our
weights and then our biases and what,
what are we going to do here?
We're going to calculate the prediction
to mold and to do that, to do that,
we're going to multiply to
input matrix by the way matrix,
and then had the biases. So
let me write that up. Um,
multiplied inputs by
weights and cad and pad.
Okay?
So it's kind of like y equals mx plus B.
It's similar kind of operations. Okay? So
we've done that and now, now we're going
to do mark softmax assumption. Okay?
When you start sigmoid softmax
is another word for six sigma.
So we've done this part, right? And
now we're going to do this part,
which is we're going to take those values
and we're going to apply a soft Max to
it. And what does soft Max
do? Does anyone remember?
Shattered on the comments and then explain
it in a second. I gonna type it out.
If someone can check that out,
I will give you a chat about if you can
tell me what the softmax function best.
So we're going to say softmax
I stopped next to this value
that we created, right? Um,
we're going to apply herself
next to his value applied
Max to value we've just created. Okay. So,
and then what does,
it's an activation function.
So now an activation function
and it does somethings.
Ouch. Okay. So let me go ahead and hand.
So I just, yes, it normalizes our value.
So what soft Max does is,
uh,
it normalizes our value.
And what do I mean by that?
It takes our value and it converts it to
a probability that we can then feed to
our output. So it's our last step
before we feed to our help. But,
so let me make sure that I typed
all this issue out perfectly. Okay.
So online 14,
TF variable,
that Zeros I said to Barry Zeroes,
oh, I need a bracket here. Okay.
Zeros. The laser focus on
what if I what I've done here.
So, um, let's see.
Interesting.
So there is a,
an extra value here.
Um,
let's see what's going down here.
Tea, half done variable. Tf
Dot Zeros. Oh, extra dot.
Okay. Uh, okay,
so now the next step is to say
how is good.
You know what it is? It's all good. Okay.
So I need to add a bracket there, I think,
right? Yeah. So I'm
heading one pair and I'm,
once you add one to here
and then we'll say compile.
And so then for the wide I use,
it's telling me what I've done wrong.
So it's saying, hey
listen buddy, listen, you
need to apply your matrix.
Multiply x, W B, TF.
Dot Add. Um, okay,
what else we got here?
Why values
and let's see.
Name acts is not defined.
Tax is not defined. Do you mean said,
oh, because I didn't define it. Yes.
So x is that value. Okay, great. Grit.
So I hit enter.
So I need to go ahead and add one
more thing for training. So, okay.
So what do we just do? We, we added
the code is going to go online. Yes,
I'm going to post it in the comments when
I'm done. We've got 15 minutes. Okay.
So what we're going to do is when,
and say you've got that soft Max value
and then we can get four outputs.
So let me type that out.
So what, what are we doing
here? We're going to feed, oh,
so we never did this part.
So we're gonna say eat
in a matrix of labels.
So let me just go over what
I've just done. Okay. So,
uh, so these are our
two placeholders, right?
So x is up here and then why
is down here, but this, right?
So one is our labels and then one,
one is our set of features.
We created our weights, we
and our biases. And then we,
this is our step right here.
We multiplied our weights by our,
by our inputs and we ended our biases.
And we,
and then we use that value
that we calculated and we
input it into the softmax
layer, which converted into
a set of probabilities. Okay,
so, so there's that. And now when did you
apply?
And we're going to do to perform a,
our training staff before the trainings.
So we've done these steps and now
step six is to perform training.
Step six is to perform
credit. All right? So, uh,
let's go ahead. And so this is,
this is the magic part of, to folks.
So if you were hearing the live session
last week, then we did this manual.
So totally to write out
what we're about to see.
What we're gonna do is we're going to
create our cost function and the cost
function. We're going to using
the mean squared error. All right?
So we did this last live session.
One of the great things about a
quarter is that we have continuity. Uh,
and so we can say,
we can say minus y this is
going to be the equation.
And I'm going to show the equation in
a second. But what this does is it says
we want to calculate the error.
So between our two wide values and uh,
we're going to divide by the number of,
so the mean square error is where we,
you take the average of the, uh,
difference in values, which is our,
Eric's the square difference.
And that's what this is doing.
So, um, so reduce some, basically
computes the element of the,
some of elements across the
dimensions of the or. So let me,
let me write that down.
We'll use some confused,
confused elements,
some elements across the
dimensions of a cancer.
And so then let me show the equation
for the 10 seconds what we just did.
So the two different
values we're using are the,
uh,
the two different guys are using is,
are the predicted the predicted values
and then the actual values for the
outputs.
That is our cost function.
We want to minimize this
cost function over time. And
uh, to do that we're going
to perform gradient descent.
So we're not,
so the great thing about tends to flow
if we can just refine in the sent had our
optimization function. We don't have
to actually write out every step.
And you radiate the scent.
Every step means where computing the
partial derivative with respect to our
input variables. What do you
know? Our case would be the uh,
which in our case we made a
set of weights and the biases.
So that's it.
I could just say we have a cost function.
We want to minimize that cost using
gradient descent and are running where it
will define how fast we want to do that.
Okay,
so do not call me during
the live session. Okay.
So let's see what we've got here.
We're going to say
why is here right and a right.
So this should be why underscoring.
So that's why that didn't work.
And so the next thing is we want to
make sure that name, why is not defined.
How about now? No, it is different
because I just updated it. There we go.
Great. So yes, so I updated the wine and
now we're going to create our session.
Um, okay, so let's initialize our session.
Is this still a part
of the training stuff?
We're going to initialize our
variables and tend to float session.
So intense or flow,
we encapsulates our computation graph.
We should,
we encapsulate our computation graph
using and utilize all variables using a
session object.
So intense flow whenever you want to do
any kind of training because the first
initialized all variables and what
additional is all variables us, they just,
it does exactly what it says,
initialize every variable
that you declared beforehand.
That means those TFR variables,
we declared it beforehand
and the placeholder objects
because we did beforehand,
right? So every enter flow generic
variable that we defined beforehand,
it's conditional as it for the session.
So I mean, this could be, you know,
this could be done under the hood as well,
but for now we're going to,
we're going to,
the textbook asks us to define a deal.
So we print our ascension, I
work session, and then we just,
we run it by using the, all the variables
that we've initialized as our inputs.
Okay.
And of course there's an,
they are so no attribute,
initial, all variable. Uh,
so what, what was that? So initialize
all variables with, hey, uh,
a set of parentheses and
then he f. Dot. Session.
Let's see what else we got here. Tf Dot
initialize. I misspelled initialize.
Okay.
Initial lines.
Great. Okay. And so here we go. Let's,
let's do that. This is the last bit, uh,
that we're going to do. This is the actual
trading. This is a training room. Okay.
So let's go ahead and do this
for every night for every, uh,
p that we have for training detox.
How many people do we have in this life?
Section? 300 people go. Awesome. Okay,
so for,
so for every training evolve,
um, if we define as 300, but what
was it? What was the number 2000?
We defined as 2000. Well, to run
our session, given our optimizer,
which is gradient that standard,
so this is where we're performing rating
descent and we're going to feed in to
where we actually feed into the
placeholders that we get fine earlier.
So those placeholders are going to be that
the first is going to be that x value,
which is going to be our teachers input x.
And the next one is going to be for the
labels, would just want it to be art,
eclipse. Why? Uh, okay. So,
okay,
how does that and so that's it. And so
now that's it really. And now we can just,
you know,
write out our debugging methods
versus going to be right out
of training.
So
if I display stack
and then we'll say,
let's run this session,
our cost function.
And then we went to,
um, and we are too hard
just to get this stuff.
We're doing this just to print it out
just so we can see, um, you know, what,
what's happening at each step.
Okay.
So our input is going to be that first,
um,
tenser and then other than that,
the other temps or that we,
yeah,
that we defined,
yeah.
Frames that
it's going to be,
yeah.
No.
So this part I'm just gonna
is this part right here because
we don't actually, it's just,
it's just long. So that's the best
way really. So what we're doing,
if we're printing out the training staff,
and let me,
let me just go ahead and run this now.
Okay.
So our first impacts there.
So it's going to be x.
It doesn't mean that
I do
that. We got here, uh, ex and put x, Y
hmm.
[inaudible] walls.
[inaudible]
session dot.
Brian.
Yeah.
Equals Yo. Okay. Yes. Okay. Okay.
Awesome. So boom. So that's
how fast the train because,
because it was only 10 values.
Okay.
It was only $10. And so what is
happening here? Let's look at this.
The first column gets, aren't
set up training steps, right?
The next one is our cost function and
the cost of entry is minimized over time.
Okay. And, and then eventually
it's finished training.
So what is the w so it ends up with a
cost function of 0.109, whatever. Right?
So this, is this good or
bad? I don't really know,
but it's better than the first cost value,
that's for sure.
We don't know if it's a good buck
cost cheat or not because we kind of
arbitrarily decide,
uh,
once there's labels were Harkes awesome.
Let's go ahead and test this out
and how are we going to test it?
I have a call slash work, Bro.
And I'm also like really sick,
which is like I don't have time for
that guide and I'm kicking this dope ass
chorus. Okay. So we're going to feed him
arc input and we're going to test it out.
We're going to see what happens now.
So this is our output. So what is it
here? So this is the prediction, right?
So we've, we've trained our model and now
we're going to do our prediction, right?
And so it's guessing,
but they're all good houses because
these values are all above. Um,
so rimmer remember I said we have y
one and y zero. So it's saying, so,
so, um, let me, let me go,
let me go back up for a second so you
guys can see what I'm talking about here.
So we defined, remember this y one and
y two. That's what it's outputting guys.
That's what it's out. And it's just a wide
one in the white too. And it's saying,
um, these values rounded in our
closest to one right on the left side.
So that means it's all one.
And the valleys on the right
are all closest to zero,
which means zero. So what it's
saying, it's, it's, it's saying
all houses are a good buck, but that's
not the case. So exact seven had a 10.
Correct. But the actual thing is
it wasn't, they weren't all good.
There were just, some of them
are good, right? So only three,
only some of them are good. So seven
out of 10 correct. Which is not bad.
How to improve. Um, maybe we could add
a hidden layer, add a hidden layer.
Had I been there,
that's what I would do.
I would add a hidden layer and then I
would try it again. So that's a kind of,
so that's my example for this.
Okay.
So let's go back to screen sharing.
Subsequent turn. Go back
to me. Hi. Okay. So, uh,
that's what we did for
that and I'm going to, uh,
I'm going to add the coaching to get
[inaudible] five minutes ended Q and a and
then we're good to go.
And I haven't,
I have a video for you guys to be out on
Friday, which I'm super excited about.
Hit me up with your
questions. Let's go. Anything.
Why do you think Jupiter, any
special perks? Um, Jupiter because,
uh, it allows you to compile it and
see what you're doing in real time.
It's great for visually looking at,
especially for data,
it's great for visually looking at what
you're doing, exactly what Jake said.
How do you choose a number of hidden
layers or not of unites while trying to
develop a neural network?
It depends on how big your data is.
The more data you have, generally the more
hidden layers, the more data you have,
the better it is to
add more hidden layers.
Um, right. Pi Torch versus
tensorflow for newcomer. Absolutely.
Tentraflow don't even don't even trip
well, but you know, pie for texting,
great architectural ideas
that I think we can, you know,
we'll see where that goes. It's a
really exciting space, guys. It's,
it's only January and we're already
seeing so much innovation in this field.
In fact, this pace of innovation
is accelerating. It's insane. Um,
how many layers should
we add for this case? Uh,
I just need to act. Um, can you say
something about Google's deep mind?
Was she running? Um, well,
I mean they haven't really done
anything this year yet, but just wait,
give them like two weeks. I expect to
see some state of Vr in something. Yeah.
Paper in like within two weeks.
How to classify an image data set.
We're going to do that in two episodes
before this course up been high level.
You want to label Dataset a
supervisor approach. Um, uh,
with labels a look at Google's in section.
You don't even have to training herself.
They were already treated when a million
images and you can use a transfer
wanting to apply that and then add in
whatever other images you want to classify
it. And because of transfer
learning and you don't need it back,
bigger data set to train it.
And I have a video on that called
guilty tends to image classifier in five
minutes. How much coffee
did you have? I had a cop.
Is it the same way session? The one
we're doing with your Udacity? Yes. Um,
anybody who has a recurrent neural nets
plans. Yes. It's coming out in three days.
Uh,
do you think that you guys,
the deep learning course apparently
for deep on a job? Yes. Uh, what image?
If you do the assignments,
okay, that does it.
Kavya and you have to duty assignments.
You can't just watch the videos,
you to do it,
do it like strive up do is I'm a
huge shower but then by the way guys,
recently, um, cause he doesn't
work. Let's take war. Did you age?
I'm 25. Did you study at university?
Yes. What computer science,
specifically robotics. Um,
anything on memory networks? Yo,
I want to do memory networks.
That's some dance shit.
That's like generative
adversarial networks.
Should that I find super
interesting at the cutting edge,
the bleeding edge of the field. But
we've got to get our basics. Now.
If you should take something
out of this slide session,
what you should take out is, are um,
three things.
One how to do gradient descent
and backpropagation to um,
uh, basic, uh, an idea of what the, uh,
the main variables are with tensorflow.
That means placeholders,
TF variables, the optimizer function,
uh, weights and biases. Okay.
Because everything's going to build off
of that can get those simple things,
then everything else is going to be much,
much busier.
And the third thing is,
um,
a softmax function. Uh,
sorry, activation functions.
Activation function is what we use
to convert numbers of probabilities.
There's several types of activation
functions. In this case we use softmax,
which university? Columbia
University. But guys,
I want to end this with one piece
of advice and then we're good to go.
A lot of what we learn is what
we tell we are capable of doing.
That's what degrees are. Degrees tell
us, it allow us to tell ourselves,
hey, I now know this. I can do it, but
we have to flip that way of thinking.
It's not about, oh, I have a degree
now I'm a computer scientist. Oh,
I have a degree now I can do x. No,
if you study something and you do it,
if you,
if you create the code and it compiles
and it runs and it gets you help with
that, you want it, you now
have the ability to do that.
So don't be restricted by the Dogma of,
Oh,
I need to read this or eat
this before it gets to this.
Think of something you want to build.
Start building and along
the way or what you need to,
to know that by the end you are going
to get really good if you've ever
engineered anything reported and you
know that if anybody asks you a problem
about it, you will know every answer. Why?
Because you had to deep dive into it to,
to be able to build that.
Okay? So that's it. Um,
all right. So believe in yourself
specifically. Believe in yourself.
The world needs you guys. Okay? We need
you. We are starting a revolution. Okay?
We are in the midst of a revolution and
like anything the world has ever seen
before and we're going to, we're
going to do some awesome shit. Okay?
We're going to do some awesome
shit. Okay. That's it. Okay.
So thanks guys for watching the
videos coming out on Friday.
It's going to be dope and uh,
continue the conversation in our
slack channel for now. I'm going to,
I'm going to, yes. I'm going to do
the math tutorial in a second. Um,
okay. So anyways, for now I've got to,
okay.
Work with you, Udacity on, uh,
something I want to go down to if you'd
ask me and just hang with them and see
what we can do. There's some really cool
people for now. That's what I got to do.
So thanks for watching.
See you guys.